the oculus quest is a VR headset that
has everything you need to play virtual
reality games like beat Sabre all in one
box there's no wires game consoles or
computers to deal with just you a
headset your controllers and the freedom
to disappear into another world no
matter where you are unless you're in a
dangerous environment like your
mother-in-law's house
you should just probably deal with the
soul-crushing reality of that until it's
over to help you set up your oculus
quest we've made this easy how-to guide
to get you up swinging sabers and
ignoring the people around you in no
time
it's like really easy to set out though
how easy is it first of all make sure
you order your oculus quest it will show
up in the mail unless you order it this
isn't a coupon for Bed Bath & Beyond you
know you can use those past the
expiration date I think you're past your
expiration date when your new oculus
quest VR system arrives be sure to thank
your mail carrier thanks mail carrier
we're gonna play beat saver open the box
and remove the oculus quest if you have
any friends watching quote a few facts
about it to make them jealous
the oculus quest headset is 563 grams or
1.2 pounds so it's very light wow that's
almost as light as your brain the
opportun brain weighs 8 pounds yeah I'm
talking about your brain the oculus
touch controllers have 6 degrees of
freedom motion tracking and don't
require a camera to track I cannot wait
to play beat cycle with these breadboard
me neither all download the app by
typing oculus quest into your smartphone
app store honestly typing no words
oculus quest might be the most difficult
part of this whole process after you
download the app log in hit set up
oculus quest turn on the quest and enter
the sync code which can be found at the
bottom right of the oculus screen and
then comes the hardest part no I'm
scared what is it you have to wait for
the firmware in it down oh god no yes
I'm so sorry give it to me straight doc
how long are we talking these things can
vary depending on your history of
internet connection it could take a few
hours but it also could only take a few
minutes but even a few minutes can feel
like an eternity when you're waiting for
something you love
it's ready let's play weed saver that's
fine I'll just watch you adjust the
headset to fit your head and place it
over your face darken here it's because
it's not on you can adjust these straps
to make it tighter you won't have to if
you got a brain as big as I do make sure
you clear enough play space so you're a
safe distance from any objects that
could cause injury to yourself or others
the oculus quest is available on May
21st and 64 gigabyte and 128 gigabyte
editions both editions come with a free
demo for beat saber if you want the full
version of beat saber you'll have to get
through me or you can just download it
from the oculus quest app on your phone
I will cut you in half
[Music]
drop their tweets I'm king of the world